AMERICAN APPAREL.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
HUMANITY, WE HAVE LOOKED INTO
THE COLD ABYSS OF NOTHINGNESS
AND AN AMERICAN APPAREL MODEL
WAS STARING BACK.
(LAUGHTER)
WE ARE GOING TO SHOW YOU A SLIDE
SHOW OF SOME OF THESE DEAD-EYED
HIPSTERS FROM AMERICAN APPAREL'S
BLOG AND FOR 250 POINTS I WOULD
LIKE YOU TO GIVE US THEIR INNER
MONOLOGUE.
HERE IS THE FIRST ONE.
YES, JULIE KLAUSNER.
>> ONE OF US PEES IN A BOX AND
THE OTHER IS A CAT.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: POINTS!
POINTS!
NEXT ONE.
YOU KNOW HOW YOU HANG OUT AT
THE TENNIS COURTS?
YES, JON DALY.
>> BELIEVE IT OR NOT I AM
LEANING ON FENCE, I NEVER
THOUGHT I COULD FEEL SO RELAXED.
>> Chris: YES!
NOW, FOR ANY MILLENNIALS OUT
THERE HE IS REFERRING TO ONE OF
THE GREATEST SHOWS EVER, "THE
GREATEST AMERICAN HERO," WILLIAM
KATT.
>> ♪ BELIEVE IT OR NOT!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Chris: DO YOU GUYS REMEMBER
THE THEME SONG?
♪ BELIEVE IT OR NOT, I'M
WALKING ON AIR. ♪
>> TAKE IT AWAY!
>> Chris: WHOA, WHOA, WHOA!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
AND THEN THE LAST ONE.
(LAUGHTER)
THE (BLEEP) HANDCUFFS ARE
AMAZING.
"NO, YOU ARE UNDER ARREST."
YES, JON DALY.
>> THE MEETING OF THE ROBIN
THICKE FAN CLUB HAS NOW COME TO
ORDER.
IS EVERYONE'S PENIS VISIBLE?
(LAUGHTER)